as president Trump is riding higher than
ever before and support for the Muller
probe is sliding imagine if the press
was actually fair about this where these
numbers would be so here's a question
for you is this the time is the time
right for the president to voluntarily
submit to an interview with Muller to
get this thing wrapped up well better to
answer that question but the president's
lawyer himself Rudy Giuliani great to
see you how are you so lots of news you
know president look great in Singapore
no doubt about it he came back in a
great mood however course you come back
and it's like right when he right when
he comes back a few hours go by in the
news about Michael Cohen perhaps
cooperating with authorities
what's your I checked into this last
night it's not so he's not he's not
cooperating nor do we care because
President did nothing wrong we're very
comfortable if he cooperates that
there's nothing he can cooperate about
with regard to president Schwab I am
absolutely certain of that from
everything I know about that
investigation including the things that
Rosenstein said to President Trump
himself that he's not involved in that
investigation
my concern is at the mower investigation
now is going on interminably and i think
it is reflected in public opinion public
opinion is disgusted with how about he's
wasted 20 million dollars and maybe he
should put out an interim report maybe
he should tell us what he's got on
collusion collusion
obstruction of justice is really totally
negated by the article 2 of the
Constitution present can fire anybody
who wants for any reason he wants
they can't even inquire about that I
don't know what he's got left
he's harassing a Michael Cohen the
Manafort case looks like it's falling
apart
they always cite well yes like twenties
could open a story you take out you take
out LT please take out the Manafort case
which may go out on lack of
authorization and now this ridiculous
witness tampering I can't even figure it
out second you got the Russians that are
all in Russia they're not coming to the
US it's a phony indictment nobody let me
get prosecuted and they were they were
harassing Hillary rallies but dressing
up like clowns
we had a lot worse than that have you
asked the special counsels office why
they haven't brought certain people in
for questioning I mean if they're gonna
focus on this Trump Tower meeting as we
know there that's part of their focus
why wouldn't they bring in the Russian
attorney who they make this big pitch
for oh she's close to Putin she's she
was trying to you know maybe because she
said doesn't happen that but she said
she was be willing to happy to come into
these helmets guys she'd be happy to
come look and they're not called one of
the things we pulled out very early in
this Muller can't indict anybody
president can't be indicted a sitting
president cannot be indicted nobody
disputes that and he's not he's so he
gets to write a report maybe I don't
even get to write a report Rosen steam I
have to write the report
so but just get it over with he's gotten
1.4 million documents 32 witnesses we've
raised no executive privilege about any
of it unlike Clinton unlike Nixon he's
got the material from which to write a
report right now except the report would
say no evidence of collusion on the part
of presidents to get into state of mind
of what the president was thinking when
he fired sublimates a State of Mind
question contract guessing game and I
think he did he can't do that and guess
it until he gets the president across
the table or written
he's not getting the president on any
kind of obstruction of justice
questioning just not gonna happen
his whole theory is cockamamie his whole
theory is I can interpret the President
had five reasons all of which a
legitimate plus an article two immunity
to do what he's doing and I think he
really did it for a corrupt reason so
I'm gonna recommend that he did
something wrong
plus his main witness there is Comey
and III don't know the horrors report in
detail I think it's gonna be a tough one
it's 500 pages the president has seen it
or he seen or three or four he gets it
before on an unedited version of it
without all the excising that they do
because I think that's where the juicy
stuff will be you and I might not get to
see that we can guess at it but at a
minimum we know already from the
league's
and you wonder how do these leaks take
place that it's going to criticize him
heavily for his first Hilary press
conference for his second Hilary press
conference and so that goes to the
credibility of how he handled the Russia
responsibilities of the attorney you
know that usurp he became the Attorney
General he's not the Attorney General
he's the director of the FBI it's like
the chief detective deciding whether the
prosecutor he wrote the report two
months before I asked Moe of when we met
with him if he would do that for us how
about writing the report now and give me
two no no that would be an in frontier
investigation to determine the the issue
of providing written answers in the next
floor limited and limited question very
quickly we're we're addressing that now
with the president Jay and the raskins
and we're all working on it and is there
a dispute among you about how to proceed
I mean I don't that's healthy to have it
probably a little bit but but all of us
know he shouldn't testify unless we get
everything we wanted he wants remember
you know him he wants to testify his
complaint is I did nothing wrong I can
stand up to any questioning what he
doesn't realize is how pernicious they
are now they're really they're really
good lawyers if they're really good
lawyers they're also not just reputable
lawyer number they've already shown a
bias and an animus against this
president the ones that have already
been cited for ethical violations for
not turning over exculpatory material
you think I'm gonna trust them
with the present United States are you
talking about who would do the
questioning are you getting into that
level of detail with I think it should
be Mahler right there Muller himself all
right when I was against I remember I
always saw wise when I would be in her I
was well Ken was an appellate lawyer
either trial or when I and he and he was
a trial war so it's his reputation at
stake shouldn't be turned over to
Quarles
shouldn't be turned over to what are you
guys worried that there are any tape
recordings that Michael Cohen might have
in his possession of conversations with
the president here about the president
that either he could have exaggerated
things to other people to like curry
favor or to look like he's bigger than
he is I'm not saying he did that but you
don't know what you guys don't know you
have some of the documents but you don't
have all the documents correct that was
turned over to the Southern District of
New York that they seized right so
you're looking at him for
village I got something better than that
I know the president for 30 years I know
him as a businessman in New York
president nighted States was a tough
businessman but just like he's done
nothing wrong in this thing
he was as clean as a whistle in the way
he might have been tough he might have
been difficult on situations like he
wasn't North Korea but he was a man of
his word and Michael Cohen I think would
tell you he's got nothing incriminating
with the president and really they
should stop going after they're
torturing the guy I mean your former
prosecutor they threatened to bankrupt
you or you know you will be bankrupt
he's switched lawyers he's trying to
find a new lawyer we don't know what
that means I don't know I didn't know
his legal team before it was not he's
not hi hi bills pile up of course they
do and go to jail for 10 years and the
reality and the reality is they're
trying to frighten them but Michael's a
tough guy I don't think that's gonna
happen and if it does I'm sure Lee isn't
gonna lie
Eric's wall well a frequent critic
Democrat on the irrelevant committee
said this no innocent people don't worry
about whether someone's going to flip on
them and also wolf let's just be real
honest presidents don't have fixers and
I think you know we're so in a thick of
this that when you take a step back and
realize every day we talk about mr.
Cohen is Donald Trump's fixer that's a
problem
innocent people don't need fixers
innocent people fix things by just
shooting straight and telling the truth
and so I think this is the beginning of
a dark dark storm come on
first of all fixer means somebody didn't
get things done people hire them in New
York they call Mets food artists to get
the a building permit they don't know
New York lingo Michael said I was I was
I was ray Donovan I was a fixer what he
meant by that was i expedited me I got
them done not illegally nobody's ever
really said anything about that until
now and this idea that a president who
is perfectly innocent has done nothing
wrong isn't gonna be framed by somebody
when they donated 36 grand to Hillary's
campaign we're at it we're at her
victory slash defeat party cried the
night she lost hey these are guys that
already have been cited for not turning
/ exculpatory and evidence about
innocent people and this idiot
congressman wants me to trust him look
I've been away or a long time that kid
doesn't always talking about are you
thank god he's not representing any but
are you also going to make an argument
about the underlying constitutionality
of the special counsel in this process
both both both on his face and as
applied because on its face the statute
just the statute itself and second the
fact that it was produced by what might
have been a totally illegal
counterintelligence investigation they
tried to make into a criminal
investigation and clearly by the Comey
memo we have to see what horror would
says tomorrow Mike professor Calabrese
said that memo could blow the whole
thing up why is that
Kellyanne Conroy's husband George I've
known him for 30 years he's a close
friend he's brilliant he thought he
might be SG at the Justice Department he
would have made a great one
he's uh he's written an article for the
hill I was in the hill where he
basically said this the this this
argument about the unconstitutionality
of the statute
he's just smashes calabrese his argument
he says it's absurd no serious legal
scholar buys into the appointments
clause argument here and he just
destroys it and you know he's Kelly
Ann's husband is there any any concern
about that at the White House no concern
about it I mean people aren't that is
not as clear an argument as let's say
their inability to indict even their
inability to subpoena if it intrudes the
article - you guys already written the
the briefs on that well more or less you
know that's done already done yeah I
figured however I would think if he it's
an undecided question so how can Conway
decide the question maybe he wants to be
out of Supreme Court but I don't think
he's gonna get the appointment Oh George
George is like you're just not getting
on the Supreme Court I think I can
predict that um is there is there
concern about it's going back to Cohen
for a moment I know because I've had
clients like this where they're they're
screws are put to them and this is where
I'm not I'm not as big a fan of
prosecutors as we love you Rudy but I'm
not as big a fan of prosecutors as some
conservatives are because with unbridled
power
power becomes abuse of discretion or I
grew them from Patrick Fitzgerald you
know what I've been with people like
seems like a little group right yeah
well it's like Darrell call me big now
house big pallet mowers yeah
Weissman now now working now Patrick
Cheryl that is calm represent you call
me yeah so he's good living yeah scooter
libby all the rest of it so so when
someone like cohen has the screws or
anybody has a screws turned on him
think you're gonna lose your family
gonna be in jail for ten years you're
gonna do this what are you gonna give us
i don't all this you're gonna tell her i
am freaked out I mean that's what the
power of prosecutors do I emphasize
greatly with Michael I do not believe he
is gonna tell a falsehood and I think
he's gonna tell the truth and we are
very comfortable with that president's
very comfortable with it he's known him
for years I what if he's in trouble on
another matter what if he's in trouble
on something else he'll deal with it and
I think I have no idea where he is I
mean I'd nor do I and I still trust in
him until they show me something to the
contrary and I haven't seen it yet
reports are that he's upset that he
hasn't obviously he can't talk to the
president now because of all but he's
reports are that he's you feeling all
alone out there also feels that way too
but we advised him Jay and I advised the
president that that would be
misunderstood now you know you would
tell your client all the time don't talk
to this look at metaphor metaphor
probably was totally innocent in talking
to these field you want to find out
about his face and they've turned it
into another charge against them because
their first charge is going under what's
your best guess about when this thing
will be decided about the testimony
because that's it I mean with everything
you hear from Muller they've interviewed
pretty much everything they want so I
believe I believe we will decide unless
something goes wrong and Alex had a
couple of things go wrong the Cohen
situation the Spygate situation but if
nothing else breaks like that possibly
this horowitz thing that major Laius i
don't know it is 500 pages all right but
we should get it done in the next week
or two
that's a decision done okay which means
then we go to battling over a subpoena
or getting them ready to for a small
tailored limited in Asia 150 subpoenas a
blank subpoenas but this
leaked I mean this came out late today
Muller has requested what could that be
about do you think is that like a that's
a mind game he's playing with you guys
okay there's more people coming in ever
gonna end
frankly if it's a mind game it works the
opposite way if he at this late stage if
he's issuing a hundred and fifty
subpoenas one of it's got nothing what
are they been doing for the last year
what where's the collusion where's the
obstruction except in their head so if
they got 250 subpoenas at this point
they everybody knows this they have no
case because Donald Trump didn't do
anything wrong have you when you talk to
Cohen or back a year ago or so and don't
know if you heard about the two and he
was going to try to get that Trump Tower
Moscow done looked at all these business
interests all over the country I mean he
didn't drop this stuff when he ran for
president and he wanted to get that done
reportedly at written a note to Putin
saying you know this thing is a log jam
here what's gonna happen they didn't go
anywhere but that's always listed in
there like the one or two or three
Russian interest contacts that Cohen
made are you aware of this have you been
discussing this with we're aware of it
and we think it has no connection wasn't
great was it green lighted by the
candidate Trump I I can't tell you that
that would be a confidence but the
reality is it wouldn't matter I mean
that nothing came of it nothing went
nothing was there was no quid pro quo
for it in essence if the President had
colluded which he didn't president will
tell you for the two years up to the in
election I didn't talk to any Russians I
don't know any Russian drink so I didn't
know it I didn't know and I don't I
don't I don't drink vodka with them so
what the hell are they talking about
what they're talking about is they have
bitter over losing this election and
some of the people right in mullahs
office were the ones crying crying like
babies the night that Hillary lost they
are trying to D legitimatize him the
president said he regrets not being able
to have a better relationship with
Russia because of all of this well
that's a national security collateral
damage of this investigation thank God
he was able to do career thank God
he's the man a man a disappointed he
could do career religion
thank you oh it's great that's it my
friend good to see you